[Music]
well Bonjour it's been a minute since we
talked and since we have a new piece of
hardware at home my guess is yes
unfortunately at a bar called hardware
in New York it took a bit of a tumble so
it's missing a spoke but still got the
choke so that parts the winner of
RuPaul's Drag Race
America's next drag superstar is
[Music]
aquaria how has life changed since you
were crowned America's next drag
superstar I mean I've been traveling
like crazy I've been working like crazy
even before then but now I mean I have
so much responsibilities so much you
know the weight of the world is on my
head and yeah it's just it's just
wonderful it's it's crazy it's stressful
it's draining but I keep telling
everyone it certainly has to be better
than losing so I couldn't be happier
beats the alternative absolutely what is
the next part of the world Aquarius
going to conquer you mean geographically
or or like what what's next for a query
in terms of drag performance and yeah so
I've got tons of shows coming up just
touring all over the world really I'm a
big performer so I'd like to bring that
show as many places in the world that I
can and yeah just uh continuing to work
on my art work on video projects fashion
projects I love staying involved with
fashion so definitely lots of fun things
to come with that so I gotta ask how
we've been able to bury the hatchet with
Mitch bebe Rexha resolve all that oh my
goodness well uh funny you asked I I
really didn't have any issue with her
beyond you know just the comments she
made I was never one of those people
like some of the crazy fans will be like
oh who is she we don't know where we
hear music I don't think we've
officially buried any sort of hatchet
but I am cool as something cold and and
I'm cold AF but I'm sure she's cool with
us and I do have to say I'm a huge fan
of her new album I think it's what
expectations fabulous album we love
Ferrari we love mine we love you know
I've been enjoying listening to it
plane rides and stuff so I guess this is
the first public announcement that we do
love the new bebe Rexha album and I'm
sure she's a lovely girl
it was just that one moment that I was
like no I
it was like when Miss Asia took a sip of
her rebel and was like no no no I'm not
finished oh yeah Hatchin I consider it
buried buried all right would you go
back and compete again do in all-stars
see I had such a blast on my season
every moment I had I tried to have as
much fun as I could except for that one
day
stop but I mean I had fun it's it's a
whole competition of doing what I love
and what I love to live my life for so
if I was asked I would definitely
consider it if it seemed to you know
work out in my favor or like you know in
a positive light but yeah it was fun I
want to have more fun yeah why not get
back on our TV screens again god forbid
yeah throw me on throw around anything
survivor Fear Factor what y'all got I
don't know
[Music]
[Applause]